[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin guten abend schön dass ihr
wieder mit dabei sind sowie katja
stresow und katja die deutsche gold
serie bei den deutschen im olympia geht
tatsächlich weiter ja es war der bislang
erfolgreichste tag für team deutschland
schirm guten abend und hier sind unsere
themen
kurs auf corona lockerungen immer mehr
bundesländer wollen die 2g regel im
einzelhandel streichen
bundeswehr an der nato ostflanke
deutschland wird zusätzliche soldaten
schicken litauen wünscht sich auch mehr
waffen
zweimal gold einmal silber rodler und
nordische kombinierer sorgen für den
bislang erfolgreichsten tag des
deutschen olympia teams
entweder ist man infiziert war es oder
kennt jemanden auf denen es zutrifft
corona ist so gut wie an jedem von uns
schon herangekommen obwohl vorsicht und
respekt immer noch vorherrschen wir
kroner rekordzahlen in deutschland
erleben befinden wir uns trotzdem auf
lockerungskurs immer mehr bundesländer
haben die 2g regel im einzelhandel
ausgesetzt bzw werden es demnächst tun
niedersachsen hatte als erstes land die
regelung schon vor weihnachten gekippt
aus hannover elisabeth schmidt
genesen geimpft ungeimpft egal seit
mitte dezember dürfen im
niedersächsischen einzelhandel durch ein
gerichtsurteil wieder alle einkaufen
auch in diesem schuh geschäft in
hannover geschäftsführer michael
schenker meyer war damals sehr
erleichtert heute sagt er finanziell hat
die 2g lockerung eher wenig gebracht
ja es ist schon so dass dadurch ein
bisschen mehr kunden gekommen sind aber
die umsätze sind deswegen nicht
exorbitant gestiegen sind sind minimal
gestiegen insgesamt ist der umsatz laut
handelsverband niedersachsen in den
wintermonaten um bis zu 20 prozent
zurückgegangen bei den infektionszahlen
lag niedersachsen lange unter dem
bundesschnitt das blieb auch nach dem 16
dezember so zweig entfiel eine ffp zwei
masken pflicht kam was hatte den
größeren effekt die 2g lockerung oder
die masken pflicht die daten sind in
deutschland tatsächlich nicht genau
genug um das zu beantworten
das beste was wir machen können sind
modelle zu bauen
und die modelle sagen im moment wenn im
einzelhandel eine gute maske nicht
herrscht dass dann der beitrag zum
infektionsgeschehen sehr gering ist
hoffnung auf weitere lockerungen kommt
jetzt ausgerechnet von seiten der
kliniken obwohl die zahl der kogit
patienten hier zuletzt wieder leicht
gestiegen ist wir gehen nicht davon aus
dass wir in den kommenden wochen eine
überlastung in den kliniken erleben
werden und deswegen ist es auch
verantwortlich jetzt schrittweise und
wirklich planvoll einzelne
beschränkungen aufzuheben oder problem
bei den crooner maßnahmen ist
deutschland bislang einen flickenteppich
mahnende worte heute aus rheinland-pfalz
ja im streben natürlich möglichst
bundeseinheitliche lösungen an die
bevölkerung trägt auch corinna maßnahmen
immer leichter mit wenn sie
bundeseinheitlich beschlossen und
besprochen sind ein trend zeichnet sich
allerdings ab 2g im einzelhandel könnte
bald deutschlandweit vergangenheit seien
und die zahlen steigen weiter an
allerdings etwas langsamer das robert
koch institut meldete
234 1250 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages das sind 25 1752 mehr als
vor einer woche
272 todesfälle kamen hinzu die inzidenz
steigt jetzt leicht auf gut
1450 aber tatsächlich fragen sich viele
wie aussagekräftig sind die zahlen in
dieser pandemie eigentlich und wie kann
man sie einordnen jürgen killias mit den
details das ist der blick auf die korona
lage in deutschland
im dunklen violett die am heftigsten von
infektionen betroffenen regionen ein
problem durch die vielzahl der fälle
kommen die gesundheitsämter tagesaktuell
nicht mehr hinterher genauere daten
liefert das rk ii mit zeitverzögerung in
den wochen berichten so kommen in der
vierten woche 20 22 mehr als eine
million fälle dazu der
altersdurchschnitt 30 jahre ein prozent
dieser infizierten müssen ins
krankenhaus 0,02 prozent der patienten
versterben ein vergleich in der letzten
woche 2020 gab es in deutschland die
bisher verheerendste cupid bilanz mit
120000 menschen waren infiziert
fast zehnmal weniger als heute aber alle
noch ungeimpft der altersdurchschnitt 49
jahre zwölf prozent mussten ins
krankenhaus der anteil der verstorbenen
4,62 prozent fast jede zwanzigste cupid
erkrankung endete tödlich also aktuell
gibt es mit omikron zwar viel mehr fälle
aber auch dank impfung viel weniger
gravierende verläufe
zum thema corona heute auch eine
wichtige entscheidung im kabinett die
regierung will die kurzarbeiter
regelungen um weitere drei monate bis
ende juni verlängert
betriebe können dann weiter leichter
kurzarbeit beantragen außerdem beschloss
das kabinett zwei bundeswehreinsätze um
ein jahr zu verlängern im südsudan sind
deutsche soldaten teil einer
un-friedensmission und im mittelmeer ist
die bundeswehr im anti terror einsatz
der nato beide kabinettsbeschlüsse
müssen noch durch den bundestag wir
bleiben bei der bundeswehr deutschland
wird jetzt in der ukraine krise seine
truppe im baltikum aufstocken das sich
durch russland bedroht fühlt so sollen
in den kommenden tagen 350 soldatinnen
und soldaten nach litauen das an die
russische exklave kaliningrad grenzt
sowie an russlands verbündeten belarus
deutschland wird schon seit 2017 den
einsatz einer multinationalen truppe in
litauen und stellt die hälfte der
bislang 1200 einsatzkräfte florian
neumann
ein kasernenhof in ruckler litauen eine
geburtstagsparty auf militärisch litauen
feiert den fünften jahrestag der nato
präsenz im land und die bundeswehr hört
so vielen dank wohl selten sogar auf
deutsch
seit 2017 trainieren hier an die 600
deutsche soldaten mit noch mal so vielen
aus fünf anderen nato nationen den
ernstfall die kampfgruppen damals eine
antwort auf die russische annexion der
krim der auftrag mit den litauischen
streitkräfte zusammen die verteidigung
des landes zu trainieren und zu üben und
das haben wir sehr intensiv getan und
das ist ein deutliches zeichen
glaubwürdiges zeichen der abschreckung
für hagen ruppelt ist heute wie üblich
nach sechs monaten dienstende weil die
vereinbarungen zwischen nato und
russland eine längere stationierung hier
verbieten dafür kommen andere deutsche
soldaten
und schon bald auf anordnung berlins 350
zusätzliche was den litauischen
präsidentin im zdf-interview
außerordentlich freut aber es reicht ihm
nicht
wir reden hier nicht mehr über quantität
wir müssen über qualität reden denn
bisher haben wir im baltikum kein system
der flugabwehr
wollte griechen spricht's und macht sich
auf den weg nach berlin wo er morgen
bundeskanzler scholz genau darum bitten
will auch hier in litauen hatte man
zuletzt zweifel an der entschlossenheit
der deutschen regierung in dieser krise
die zusätzlichen soldaten die man jetzt
hierher schickt haben manchen zweifel
vielleicht ausgeräumt die liste an
erwartungen aber ist deutlich länger
völlig normal wenn eine neue ministerin
eine neue mitarbeiterin in ihr ressort
holt aber das was annalena baerbock eine
traumbesetzung nennt ist für die
opposition eine krasse fehlbesetzung es
geht um die berufung von greepeace
chefin jennifer morgen ins außenamt über
die personalie und die aufregung darüber
andreas ruppert
gestatten jennifer morgen 55 jahre alte
us-amerikanerin und künftig
sonderbeauftragte der bundesregierung
für internationale klimapolitik im range
einer staatssekretär annalena baerbock
holt sich mit der greenpeace-chef in
buchstäblich die internationale
klimapolitik ins haus wer jennifer
morgen jetzt für das deutsche team
gewinnen konnten
das ist für mich eine traumbesetzung und
ein wichtiges signal für den
internationalen klimaschutz
die personalie außerdem ein klares
zeichen welche rolle künftig die
klimapolitik hier spielen soll das
auswärtige amt als zentrum deutscher
klimaprojekte in der welt deswegen auch
diese neue stelle die es ja bisher so
auch noch nie gegeben hat mit einer
person die die unterschiedlichen
dimensionen unser klima herausforderung
abdeckt für die cdu ist diese
personalentscheidung lobbyismus
dass gerade eine umweltaktivistin die
eben auch in diesem bereich gearbeitet
hat und diese art des arbeitens gewohnt
ist das ganz offensichtlich jetzt den
regierungshandeln übertragen soll und da
habe ich wirklich meine zweifel ob das
den interessen unseres landes dient
jennifer morgen ist in der deutschen
politik keine unbekannte war 2013 im rat
für nachhaltige entwicklung der
bundesregierung ab 2014 steht sie an der
spitze von greenpeace als aktivistin in
die politik das gehe nicht lautet daher
ein weiterer vorwurf wenn ich für
deutschland spreche dann natürlich werde
ich die positionen der bundesregierung
vertreten nicht von mir persönlich nicht
von irgend eine andere organisation am
ersten märz tritt jennifer morgen ihr
neues amt an als erste klima
sonderbeauftragte für deutschland
für die freien wähler tritt am kommenden
sonntag die brandenburgische
kommunalpolitikerin stefanie gebert zur
wahl des bundespräsidenten
beziehungsweise des bundespräsidenten an
die 41 jährige trifft dabei auf
amtsinhaber frank walter steinmeier die
afg hatte in ökonomen max otte nominiert
die linken den arzt gerhard trabert
stefanie gebauer ist in kremmen
vorsitzende der
stadtverordnetenversammlung und
wissenschaftliche mitarbeiterin der
brandenburgischen landtags fraktion die
promovierte astrophysikern will mit
ihrer kandidatur frauen mut machen eine
führungsaufgabe zu übernehmen
der brh exit er sollte großbritannien
einen wirtschaftlichen schub geben zu
alter größe zurückführen so zumindest
die versprechen der befürworter jetzt
ein jahr nach der endgültigen schaltung
von der eu sieht die realität ziemlich
nüchtern aus ein parlamentarische
bericht kommt zu dem ergebnis der brh
exit bringt der britischen wirtschaft
vor allem höhere kosten viel bürokratie
und lange wartezeiten an den grenzen
diana zimmermann
angriff ist die beste ablenkung boris
johnson hat die mitarbeiter die in
vergangene woche reihenweise verlassen
haben ersetzt und jacob bismarck als
neuen minister für brechtsche chancen
ernannt der einzige job in der praxis
bisher geschaffen habe kommentierten
böse zungen der premier macht derweil
andere für die probleme mit dem eu
austritt verantwortet der vertrag
verlangt gar nicht dass alle
nahrungsmittel medikamente und pflanzen
systematisch gedeckt werden wir müssen
und werden das in ordnung bringen und
wenn die eu keinen gesunden
menschenverstand zeigt werden wir
artikel 16 natürlich aktivieren
mit der kündigung des nordirland
protokolls im dreck sind vertrag zu
drohen soll auch davon ablenken was ein
heute vorgelegter parlamentsbericht
feststellte der brh exit hat keine neuen
kräfte freigesetzt nur mehr
handelshindernisse
viele unternehmen berichten dass sie
wirklich zu kämpfen haben mit
verzögerungen an den grenzen und extra
kosten für bürokratie wir haben der
regierung immer wieder gesagt ihr müsst
den kleineren unternehmen helfen der
praxis sagt das statistikamt wird
großbritannien langfristig doppelt so
teuer zu stehen kommen wie die pandemie
rund 95 milliarden euro pro jahr
lebensmittel und energiepreise steigen
hier besonders stark auch wegen des
drecks it
es ist immer dasselbe diese regierung
produziert chaos schützt ihre freunde
und es die arbeitende bevölkerung zahlen
schon jetzt sind die schlangen von dover
lang rauben zeit und geld der
finanzausschuss warnt dass sie nach der
pandemie bei normalem waren- und
personenverkehr noch länger werden
könnten
die briten würden sagen er ist changing
alles verändert sich und das gilt auch
für die deutsche automobilindustrie
2021 gab es so wenig neuzulassungen wie
nie zuvor das hat mit corona zu tun mit
lieferengpässen aber eben auch mit
großer transformation weg vom verbrenner
hin zum e auto china hat das sehr viel
schneller umgesetzt als der frühere auto
primus deutschland lothar becker
der ebase u5 ein chinesisches
elektroauto nicht billig aber günstig
nicht perfekt aber ordentlich in china
dürften in diesem jahr über vier
millionen elektroautos verkauft werden
allerdings schaffte es im letzten jahr
nicht ein einziges deutsches modell in
die top ten der chinesischen
verkaufsliste für batterieelektrische
fahrzeuge besser belegt die plätze zwei
und drei china ist deshalb wichtig weil
es absolut größte markt der welt ist und
in china hat ganz konsequent auf
elektroautos gesetz dort ist das
batterieelektrische autos zu hause dort
hat tesla seine große fabrik in shanghai
dort werden von den chinesen wie zb die
oder neo oder anderen elektroautos in
großen stückzahlen gebaut 61 prozent
aller batterieelektrischen neuwagen der
welt wurden 20 21 in china verkauft der
marktanteil der deutschen hersteller war
in der antriebsart allerdings gering mit
gerade mal vier prozent der reinen
elektroautos bei fahrzeugen mit
verbrennungsmotoren haben deutsche
autobauer einen marktanteil von 21
prozent in china
technologisch sind wir weit vorne wir
investieren bis 20 26 und 220 milliarden
in neue antriebe und innovationen
wichtig ist dass wir jetzt auch
europäische über halbleiterproduktion
batterieproduktion und andere punkte
nachdenken ansonsten ist die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit gefährdet die
transformation hin zum batterie
elektroauto ist entscheidend für
deutschlands autobauer um nicht den
internationalen anschluss zu verlieren
als hätte eine bombe eingeschlagen so
die schockierten anwohner und die
polizei meint nicht auszumalen wenn noch
passanten auf der straße gewesen wären
autos in flammen gestern abend in führt
weil ein betrunkener lkw fahrer nach
einem unfall noch mehr als 30 autos
gerammt hatte das feuer griff auf ein
haus über es ist vorerst nicht mehr
bewohnbar drei menschen wurden verletzt
der 50-jährige fahrer festgenommen der
schaden laut polizei ein mindestens
sechsstelliger betrag
so wir sind jetzt beim sport bei katja
und bei drei medaillen läuft könnte man
sagen läuft und fährt auf kufen im
eiskanal denn auf die deutschen rodler
ist mal wieder verlass heute gab es
sogar doppelt freude bei den
doppelsitzern denn erstmals seit 1992
gewann deutschland gold und silber durch
die duos tobias wendl und tobias arlt
und toni eggert/sascha benecken
mit diesem sieg schreiben tobias wendl
und tobias arlt rudel geschichte
die beiden sind das erste doppelsitzer
duo mit drei olympia goldmedaillen in
serie
wir sind kämpfer wisse besser und zum
höhepunkt oder zur olympischen spielen
alle vier jahre mit uns rechnen mit
einem perfekten lauf landen die beiden
mit einem hauchdünnen vorsprung von 99
tausendstelsekunden vor ihrer
dauer-rivalin toni eggert und sascha
benecken
wir sind super glücklich dass wir das
heute versilbern durften und ist noch
ein bisschen luft nach oben für das
rekord wars bayern ist die medaille das
insgesamt fünfte olympische gold
[Musik]
noch eine erfolgsgeschichte knapp eine
woche war kombinierer vinzenz geiger in
isolation weil er kontakt zum kroner
positiven eric frenzel hatte die hat ihm
offensichtlich aber wenig anhaben können
denn auf sensationelle art und weise
wurde er olympiasieger
es war diese unglaubliche schlussspurt
als der 24-jährige vinzens geiger seinen
führenden teamkollegen johannes rydzek
einfach überholte und hinter sich ließen
nicht nur ihn die gesamte konkurrenz
über 10 kilometer eine fulminante
energieleistung der olympiasieg in der
nordischen kombination
nachdem corona chaos bei den
kombinierern glänzte der oberstdorfer
vinzens geiger als kombinierer könig
die haben einfach so gut gefühlt hat er
war sei nicht funktioniert hat
unglaublich silber ging an den norweger
jörgen grabe und bronze sicherte sich
der österreicher lukas greiderer geigers
teamkollegen johannes rydzek und julian
schmid belegten am ende die plätze fünf
und acht
dicke tränen der enttäuschung gab es
indes auf dem slalom hang in ihren job
zum einen von der großen favoritin
michaela schiffen aus den usa und leider
auch von lena dörr die führte nach dem
ersten durchgang verpasste dann aber als
vierte die so ersehnte medaille
am ende fehlen ihr nur sieben
hundertstel aufs treppchen lena dürr
kleine fehler im zweiten lauf kosten ihr
das erhoffte
gerade ist einfach nur bitter weil es
nicht mal nicht mal weit weg war sondern
einfach nur ganz knapp sogar auf dem
ersten ja eigentlich noch wirklich knapp
gold holt die slowakin petra wilke war
vor katharina lins berger aus österreich
und der schweizerin wendy holdener eine
weitere herbe enttäuschung auch für top
favoritin michaela chiffren aus den usa
nach ihrem ausscheiden im riesenslalom
endet für sie der olympischen slalom
ebenfalls vorzeitig nach nur vier toren
sehr bitter aber beide haben noch
chancen
danke katja zum schluss haben wir noch
was fast royales und zwar von der
königin der brit award denn die heißt
spätestens seit gestern
ja gleich drei preise gewann sie bestes
album bester song und artist of the year
und gleich drei mal stach sie damit
ihren den anderen superstar des abends
aus dell ist jetzt die erfolgreichste
künstlerin in der geschichte der brit
awards und sagte natürlich auch
musikalisch danke
[Musik]
so und mit diesem musikalischen ausklang
in die lottozahlen und die lauten wie
folgt 16 25 26
32 33 45 und die superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto punkt zdf.de und
auf der zdf textseite 557
katja honnefer hat uns schon gesagt
sonne im norden sonne im süden und
dazwischen der regnerisch mehr dazu
gleich marietta slomka meldet sich wie
gewohnt um 21.45 mit dem heute-journal
und wir von heute 19 team morgen dann
wieder wir sagen schön dankeschönabend
für sie
[Musik]
ein abend von südwesten setzte sich die
sonne heute immer besser durch sehr gut
zu erkennen sind aber auch die
schneeflächen hier in den alpen gut zu
erkennen auch über den ort sind über dem
atlantik diese schauer bewölkung die
einfach andeutet dass dort die luft
etwas kälter ist bei uns fällt aus den
dichten wolken in norddeutschland auch
in der nacht noch regen sonst ist es zum
teil klar und es bildet sich nebel die
temperaturen sinken in süddeutschland
auf plus 3 bis minus fünf grad da wird
es also kalt genug für glätte im norden
ist es bei 7 bis 4 grad milder morgen
gegen die höchsttemperatur meister bei
78 grad milder wird es im südlichen
brandenburg auch in sachsen südlich der
donau und am oberrhein mit 10 bis 14
grad und man zieht ein kleines tief vom
niederrhein bis zur ostsee das bringt
also regen mit und nachmittags lockern
die wolken hier an der nordsee schon
wieder auf deutlich freundlicher ist das
richtung südosten und besonders am
alpenrand sehen sie häufig die soll dann
kommt ein kleines stürmische steve heran
und das bringt uns schnee regen und
graupelschauer vielleicht auch mal kurze
gewitter am freitag es wird deutlich
kälter bei zwei bis acht grad der
samstag wird zwar ähnlich kalt aber sehr
viel sonniger guten abend